hey let's talk Avengers because I woke
up to an Avengers endgame trailer no I
didn't think I was gonna wake up to that
I thought it was just more chatter like
trailers a-comin Mike uh-huh dead holy
[ __ ] it actually happened it starts off
Tony Stark is on the ship he's adrift in
space he's out of food he's out of water
he's sending a message to Pepper Potts
or at least for Carter yet on his Iron
Man helmet which made me think one thing
did nebula just totally bail did you
leave me there to die nebula was there
with him right I guess how I remember it
I'm second-guessing myself that's the
ultimate like hey can I get a ride with
you and then you can actually give them
a ride but you're like an again I gotta
go if they just leave but you know
they're gonna be alright it's like that
only you leave and you know they're
probably gonna die there's a pretty dick
move nebula I'm just saying there's a
reason Gamora with Stannis as a favorite
you see Hawkeye Hawkeye is back here
just look in his eyes like yeah my
family totally [ __ ] disappeared right
in front of my face oh god I just
thought of something dark Tony Stark
recording that message on this Iron Man
helmet for Pepper Potts would have
pepper disappeared what if he gets back
and they're like no she's gone she was
part of the unlucky 50% nice message so
Tony really came from the heart my
concern or at least thought is Stannis
gonna be in this movie at all you see a
shot of him with his gloves he's hanging
out in his utopic man cave he's crazy
he's hanging out in his paradise but
like does he need to be in this movie I
think he does imagine if he gets wind of
them trying to undo what he did he'd
probably do that done what is he going
to like the fact that Thanos succeeded I
don't see a reason for him to be in this
movie really and Thanos was the sweetest
part of Avengers infinity war and others
just thought I have I'm gonna miss that
dude how do you up the scale how do you
make it better like I don't expect this
movie to be better than Avengers
infinity war but I do want to see the
damage control I do want to see them try
to undo what happened okay I'm gonna
dress this I'm gonna dress the
narcissism do the Santos make that
shrine dedicated to him with his armor
like that's kind of dick that's an
egotistical move you could talk about
I'm wiping out 50% alive for the
betterment of life but in the end
someone with that kind of ego now you
just did it to do your thing to make
your mark on the universe I'm actually
surprised I show what they show at the
end of this trailer like Scott Lang
being there that kind of makes the
post-credits scene in ant-man and the
wasp kind of null and void at those
point then again we knew he was gonna be
fine we knew who's gonna get out of
there like what it was just the end of
ant-man now know so I suppose is not a
spoiler it's a no [ __ ] scenario what you
thought he was gonna be there forever
but the look on their faces when they're
like that's the front door but that's
interesting because why are they so
amazed that he's there my thought on it
I imagine it's because of the 50% thing
even how Black Widow says it in this
trailer she's like Thanos wiped out 50%
of life but what if it was a number
that's not divisible by two like does it
round up around down now I got to think
about that but I'm gonna assume it's
exactly 50% like in a world with
nanotech I'm pretty sure that can take a
pretty accurate census of the world
population so let's assume it's exactly
50 but Scott Lang shows up it's no
longer exactly vivid it's 50% plus one
now it's another like it was 50%
counting that you were part of it but
you dodged it how it again how is the
50% quantified does it quantified like
every world has 50% of their citizens
wiped out or is life from all worlds
counted as one and it wipes out 50% of
the collective example if you have earth
and Alpha Centauri is at 50% of Earth
and 50% of Alpha Centauri counting as
50% of those or can it be 70% of Earth
gets wiped out and 30% of Alpha Centauri
counting as 50% of both or can you have
nobody from Earth get wiped out and 100%
of Alpha Centauri then again that does
hinge on the population of the two
worlds and how they compare to each
other like 20% of Alpha Centauri could
equal 100% of her so if it goes on the
cosmic scale like that I guess that kind
of flies in the face of going Oh Scott
Lang you're here you shouldn't be you
should be disappeared I don't know maybe
there's just huge ant-man fans maybe
they're really pumped he's at the front
door I think cap lost his beard to the
snap like his beard counts as a living
life form in and of itself it was just
like Shay on and to be honest a lot of
people thought we were gonna get this
trailer earlier I totally see why they
waited this long for it again I suppose
that's comparatively waited this long /
what you would expect like I expected we
would have gotten this trailer sometime
in the summer but waiting on it totally
makes sense because they talk about what
happens at Avengers if any were like
yeah 50% of people disappeared
spoiler alert in case you didn't see
that movie like after a certain amount
of time you can talk about spoilers like
I could say Darth Vader is Luke
Skywalker's dad and not feel too bad
about it talking about everybody
disappearing in Avengers infinity war
I'm still like but they do in the
trailer cuz you kind of have to if
you're gonna address what they're doing
now so I get why this trailer didn't
come out earlier than December but in
the end this was a fine trailer a fine
treat to wake up to I don't want a lot
of trailers for this one we're all gonna
watch it like maybe one more trailer a
month or two before the movie comes out
and after that TV spots sure that's it
it's Avengers endgame what you need a
lot of trailers for Avengers
endgame you don't think everybody's
going to watch Avengers endgame you
don't think everybody who's been along
for the MCU rides going to be there for
Avengers endgame the culmination of the
past ten years of their MCU cinematic
experience you don't need a lot of
trailers for this one if I like this one
showed exactly what we needed what we
wanted to say and that's it all right so
the trailer for Avengers endgame great
titles here like Doctor Strange said
this is the end game good call back
throw back full circle moment in the
title but anyhow what did you think of
the trailer whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]